Jackie files if you're out there this
one's for you did I draw you cute or
should I draw you
oh you draw me however you want to draw
me okay I said old like it was a crime
you know what the hell when do you think
I went to college Jackie
17:53 the same age that Lincoln was born
Kevin Jackie me not a lot of hair that
was mean why would you say that it's
like Pokemon it's so popular that even I
know majin buu and I think majin buu is
very cute I don't know who majin buu is
are you just gonna do voices in this
entire episode it's me Mario
these are my friend Yoshi oh that's
Pikachu that's a really good one just
draw Jackie because here's the thing if
I draw you in my style
it's just gonna look like I mean with
like long black hair spider-verse
is the best movie ever created it's
really good miles that spider-man love
Gwen Stefani loved Peter Parker Peter B
Parker Peter C Parker not going Stefani
Peter D Park when Stacy heater edit
record my favorite spider-man from
spider-verse was Peter B Parker do you
want to know why is it cuz you're old
I'm making you draw a comic book
character from my era the 1700s stop it
this is this is close enough but it's
not great you're scared of the I love
drawing Homer I am scared of my critique
I'm not gonna lie you're afraid of the
animators worried because which was he
draws Homer for a living like that's
what it does you know what we do for a
living what we are wrong for a living
the Internet we draw incorrectly for
living on the internet we draw other
people's characters wrong so that people
can laugh at us so honestly so honestly
we're doing our job right we're doing
our job if it's wrong you know yeah yeah
but we're really sorry that we can
really start really really driving our
folks really trying or isn't that wild
and wacky stop saying la be wacky isn't
that wild and wacky with Barry Allen and
Jackie my Cintiq so I remember Dragon
Ball Z mostly from the Super Nintendo
game there's a super Dukey oh hell yeah
there was it like a fighting game yeah
it's like Street Fighter but it's mostly
just you throwing giant fireballs and
energy at each other that sounds great
yeah that's all I want to do in real
life you just want to throw giant
fireballs at me yeah Jackie why wouldn't
you I thought we were friends
no you know I'm really good at doing
toad okay give me some of your toad
right I know that they need to collect
the Dragon Balls to make their wish come
true
wait are we sure this isn't pokemon no
give me your best Mario but I know games
are great and if you have the excess
funds to purchase one I highly recommend
it I don't know switch you're different
I hate you already when they're like
juice enough to become Super Saiyans
when they're juicing up you know what I
mean don't pretend like you don't know
what I'm talking say Goku is juice
enough don't like rocks and stuff like
flow oh yeah whenever they're juicing up
stop seeing juice enough juicing up
Jackie
Wow Justice League yeah I think I love
them do you
know who the Justice League are super
you sound very confident
I like bumbling buffets you really do
I like the dumb line that's your type
I'm gonna beep it on purpose you're
gonna what I'm gonna beef it on purpose
this beef it mean Jackie because I have
a definition of what beef it means you
don't know what befit me I mean means
you need a mistake right also when I was
growing up though beef it meant to fart
even it stop saying beefing it smell so
bad and today we're gonna be drawing my
neck hurts today we're gonna be drawing
Marvel superheroes from memory didn't we
already do that we did DC I don't know
we did Justice League whatever our
universe is straight whatever they're
all the same guy that's disconcerting
okay I gave him way too much crotch
here's a saddle right I think he is a
shell no really what is marios it off
the shell part why are you drawing a
horse
I think I'm drawing a horse Jackie I
think you're thinking of a great horse
of a great horse to draw someone is a
very precious thing and I don't want to
disappoint you I'm gonna cry
stop it I mean from disappointment well
at first they didn't want to make
spider-man cuz they were like oh nobody
likes spiders like this is gonna be
gross that was Stanley's story behind it
and he was like I'll show them I'll make
him the most popular superhero in the
world yeah for some reason he's been old
his whole life in this scenario he's
already like 90 it was kind of looking
more like a McDonald's character right
now than a than a Justice League
character I apologized to Barry Allen
and his son Wally West oh wait is his
son no honey chunk rat is like it's
wacky is he wild and wacky he's wild and
wacky with overwatch his hair is on fire
seriously kind of and he is missing two
limbs Kevin what's your favorite episode
of The Simpsons so my favorite episode
of The Simpsons is called Lisa's
substitute it's an episode in the second
season where Lisa has a very inspiring
teacher who ends up going away because
he's a substitute teacher yeah but he
gives her the sweetest note in the world
and tells her all
look at it when you are starting to
doubt yourself and as he goes away she
opens it up and it says you are Lisa
Simpson it's so sweet
yeah but then my other favorite episode
is the one so cute oh my god you okay
that was so cute and that was just the
synopsis you should watch it oh my god
you guys what I'm a mess I mean if you
want to go into a story he's undead the
devil being the devil gave him like
demonic superpowers put him back on the
earth but then wiped his memory so he
didn't know who his wife was oh so that
sucks yeah I will draw what I think
spawns logo would be follow your heart
and it's skull cuz Goths love human
anatomy if your favorite superhero is
venom you're either a really edgy 13
year old boy or a 25 year old woman that
just got out of a long relationship mine
is very plain mmm I am gonna warn you
though there's a lot of crotch come on
again bringing up the crotch there's a
lot of crotch come on you'll see he's
just gonna have to deal with it I'm just
gonna deal with flashes groin plant his
crotch his costume is so simple that
there's no way to mask his groin I mean
there is but you know Kevin I'm just
gonna let it slide this time cuz I don't
want to hear you say crotch again I'm
just letting you know a lot of crap you
really overplayed the crotch way you
described it I was thinking you gave him
like a basketball in there you know what
a good anime face really yeah and you
know what else I'm gonna say it looks
nothing like Kevin it does not look like
Kevin at all it's got to be held at
animate though cuz it's very specific
yeah I'm glad we didn't do it I know I'm
very nervous don't be scared Kevin all
he'll do is say it's awful and draw over
to make it perfect wow this is like
Homer Simpson meets George Jetson okay
you're definitely a lot closer than me
it felt right when I was working on the
sketch and you're right now that it's
done we're all geniuses in hindsight
Jackie oh my god I just realized that
did not draw his other hand oh yeah I'm
just gonna beef this hand huh you're
gonna be fit just gonna beat this hand I
knew it I knew that would catch on we
just we just look up at each other we're
just looking at each other like what are
you just like what do you look like look
like look like jerk so I think I just
drew venom and goth clothes you're not
far off
I don't like spawn listen if you were a
dude like me in the 90s you are all
about spawn it's a good thing I'm a
woman like me in the 2010 and I love
instead dirty pyromaniacs
okay remember the thing you can do to
make it look like your pencil is wobbly
yeah we get it Jackie you finished
before I did I'm trying to entertain
them you know what Kevin this is why you
need to believe in yourself Jackie I do
believe you need to trust your gut like
Homer has a gut am i right Mike that's
right I did my best low-budget todd
mcfarlane style todd mcfarlane style
writer my writer man yeah yeah he would
be very upset if he saw this and if he
saw this yeah but it's definitely
spider-man it's definitely stop doing
that yeah all right
switcheroo switcheroo buckaroo I was
gonna say curse words this looks like
Aquaman cosplaying junk rat why'd you
give him like an earring because he's
like a he's like a crazy guy crazy dude
I'm real slow when it comes to drawing
I'm real slow when it comes to thinking
am i right ladies to brain cells hands
up that's millennial talk for you so the
fact that I got closer than I thought
that I did I will say is a compliment to
your descriptive abilities and you know
what me getting really far off is an
insult to you
[Music]
you